what was that demonic what was that
acronym
spare it just rolls off the tongue right
sphere now we did symmetry we did the
factorization we worked out where the
asymptotes were
we worked out where the intercepts
were not
okay and that was enough that was enough
okay we didn't need to do this this
region's business that i said right at
the end okay but this is a really really
powerful powerful tool so to illustrate
how powerful this is right uh and why
you really need it for these other kinds
of graphs i want you to consider
a bit of a thought experiment with you
okay
if i give you two numbers
and are both positive
okay
if i give you two numbers that are both
positive and i multiply them even though
you don't know what the sizes of the
numbers are
you can tell me with an absolute
certainty you can tell me the sign of
the product right
like will it be positive or negative
answer positive because there's nowhere
for a negative to creep in there right
in exactly the same way if i give you
two positive numbers and instead of
asking for the product
if i ask you for the quotient
you can tell me again even though you
don't know the size
it will still be positive right does
that make sense
okay and exactly the same way if for
instance i gave you a negative
and a negative
right you know what the sign is going to
be if i gave you a negative and
a positive you would know what the sign
is going to be and i can give you any
number of these right like i can give
you
any series of positive or negative
numbers and you'll be able to tell me
that sign at the end does that make
sense
okay now here's what i want you to wrap
your head around this trick here with
knowing the sign of something and
therefore knowing the sign of the
product or the question okay
it doesn't just work with numbers it
doesn't just work with numbers it works
with functions too because functions are
just going to produce numbers that are
still getting positive or negative and
therefore when you take the products or
questions you'll still get positives or
angles does that make sense
okay so
i want you to consider with me a
particular set of
three factors which ones did i pick i
picked
x
x minus two and x plus one okay now draw
for me just a small but wide set of axes
like this okay
in a light color in a light color
what i'd like you to do is to graph
these three lines they're called factor
lines and you'll see why in a second
okay they're just straight lines just
straight lines so what are you going to
look like something like this
okay here are my factor lines they're
just straight lines they're all parallel
though that doesn't matter as you'll see
shortly i've got x plus one and then x
and then x minus two
okay
now these factor lines they break up the
cartesian plane into chunks into chunks
according to
where they cross the axis or more
specifically where they change sign okay
so for instance if i put in some more
lines here it's going to get pretty busy
i apologize
okay have a look over here on the far
left hand side of this graph
to the left of negative 1 because that's
the value there right i've got negative
1 and i've got 0 and i've got 2.
over here on the leftmost side right
all three of my factors
are
if i drive this other way negative
negative and negative right do you see
that
so when you take the product
or the question of three negative
numbers the sign will be
negative right it will also be negative
i'm just gonna have to use this
negative now negative is down here
see that
negative is down
here okay so no matter how i combine
these three factors because they're all
negative the result whether i'm
multiplying or dividing or multiplying
or multiplying or whatever will be
negative make sense
okay now as i cross over this minus one
line i transition to this little zone
here okay have a look carefully at this
zone i have two factors that are still
negative
but one of them has become positive see
that
so the two negatives are going to cancel
and give me a positive and the third one
will also be positive so a negative and
a negative and a positive will give me
a positive so i'm going to be up here
now in this little region
okay i'm shading regions right if you
have a pencil rather than a pacer you
can actually shade as you'll see in a
second
now you can kind of see
like you don't need to think all that
hard now for the rest of the diagram
really every time you cross one of these
intercepts you flip over right because i
have three negatives negative
two negatives positive
here i have negative positive positive
which therefore means
negative it just flips around every time
can you see that
and then lastly of course by the time i
get to here all three of my factors are
positive so i'm going to be up here
all right now here's what i mean by
saying this regions thing even though it
can be confusing initially
it is super super powerful okay
no matter what way you combine these
three factors you can divide or multiply
them in any combination they will all
pass through like the combination of
these will all pass through these four
regions
no choice